one division started with many questions
and it ended with a bang
but although the mcu's most mysterious
project
answered many of its biggest questions
there was
a lot still left to speculation after
the last post-credits scene
here are the biggest unanswered
questions in one division
not only would it have been really cool
to get a doctor strange cameo in one
division it's genuinely a little
puzzling
what the narrative reasoning could be
behind it not happening
for example think about his appearance
in 2017's thor ragnarok
thor and loki are only in new york city
a few minutes before strange kidnaps
loki from a safe distance while leaving
an
invitation for thor when thor accepts
the invite to strange's
sanctum sanctorum he learns loki is on a
watch list
strange keeps of threats to earth and
that he's understandably concerned about
his return
so i keep a watch list of individuals
and beings from other realms that may be
a threat to this world
your adoptive brother loki is one of
those beings
so dr strange knows within minutes not
only that loki is back on earth but
knows where he is with such specificity
that he can capture him with a spell
that doesn't affect
anyone else but a woman who we
eventually learn is a legend among
practitioners of magic
creates a mystical pocket reality in the
middle of new jersey
resurrects her dead lover creates two
twin sons from scratch
and takes an entire town hostage in the
process
and strange couldn't even take a quick
trip to westview to find out what's
going on
this may be addressed in the upcoming
film doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness one possible explanation is that
since one division takes place not long
after the events of 2019's
avengers end game strange is too busy
dealing with a fallout from that
conflict
to handle west view or even be aware of
it
the pen ultimate one division episode
ends with the surprise reveal that sword
has successfully reassembled
the deactivated vision's body and made
him look
more or less like the robot version of a
white walker after a brief and
scary reunion with wanda the white
vision spends most of the rest of the
finale locked in battle with the magic
vision that wanda created in west view
the white vision ultimately abandons his
mission to kill wanda
and her vision after the latter unlocks
his memories
though he doesn't change sides to help
wanda
he simply leaves the scene altogether
so where does he go and perhaps more
importantly
what has the restoration of his memories
affected
do they restore his sense of humanity
you would think if that were the case
that he would leap at the chance to help
wanda but he doesn't
there's also the option of turning on
his sword handlers for payback
but that doesn't happen either at least
not that we see
if only you had a little more vision
that's a good one hayward perhaps the
best answer is that
overloaded with all this new data the
white vision retreats somewhere to
process his new existence
we certainly hope to see him again and
learn what's become of him
and in exciting news paul bettany told
esquire in a march 2021 interview that
he is indeed planning to return to the
role
what will become of him next for now
he's just one of the biggest question
marks one division leaves behind
there are hints throughout one division
of wanda having done
something to the children of westview
but we don't get a clearer picture of
what's been going on
until the series finale when agatha
frees dotty's mind we learned that her
real name is sarah and that for the
whole time wanda's controlled west view
sarah has been separated from her
daughter if you could just let her out
of her room
if i could just hold her please
presumably the rest of westview's
families find themselves
in similar situations the question is
why would one to keep these families
separated the most obvious answer is
that children are meant as hostages to
keep west view's populist dancing
towanda's tune
but wanda seems to have everybody firmly
under her psychic control so
why would hostages even be necessary
another possibility is that wanda isn't
willing to psychically violate
children the same way she does their
parents so instead she separates them
hey don't get me wrong you've handled
the ethical considerations of this
scenario as best you could
it's also possible that this is another
product of wanda's trauma
wanda's experienced a lot of loss losing
everyone in her biological family along
with vision so
maybe the separation of west view's
families is simply a reflection of how
all of wanda's loved ones have been
taken from her when you let us sleep
we have your nightmares when a stork
shows up in episode 3
now in color it seems to be the only
thing in west view that wanda's powers
can't control after monica arrives wanda
tries
multiple times to send the bird away in
most cases the stork disappears for
moments or two
but it always comes back the stork makes
a very brief reappearance in episode 7
as wanda's control over west view begins
to slip
and the shapes of her illusions start
changing all on their own
so what was going on with that stork why
was it there and why didn't
wanda's powers have any lasting effect
on it the best answer we can come up
with is
only a partial one the stork is somehow
connected to the arrival of the twins
billy and tommy
it shows up in the episode in which the
twins are born but
obviously according to folklore storks
deliver children to their parents
more importantly wanda's powers can't
dismiss the bird just as her powers
can't control the twins
remember that early in episode 5 when
wanda decides to use her powers to force
the twins to stop crying
she's confused to learn her powers won't
work on them
assuming we're right that still doesn't
explain what the stork
actually is was it an unconscious
manifestation wanda created or
does it represent an unrevealed outside
source
which brought wanda her twin children
for reasons
even she doesn't know one of the most
interesting moments of the series finale
comes when wanda
walks through westview with the victims
of her hex glaring at her
she has a brief exchange with monica who
tells her the residents will never know
what she sacrificed for their sake
and wanda reports that it wouldn't
change what they think of her
wanda tells monica she's sorry for the
pain she's caused
not long after she makes her exit from
the town
it's more than a little disturbing that
wanda doesn't bother to take
any time to apologize to the people of
west view for what she's done
wandavision doesn't tell us exactly how
long wanda's hex
has been up but it's been at least a few
weeks
so for all that time wanda has kept an
entire town
psychically and physically hostage
she has separated them from their lives
and separated them from their children
she has violated them mentally and
physically
and on her way out of town she
apologizes
to monica clearly wanda didn't
consciously intend to inflict pain on
anyone else but that doesn't make her
any less responsible for what happened
she's right when she says nothing would
change what they think of her but
so what acknowledging her crimes and
apologizing for them
is the absolute least she could do and
she neglects to do it that's not
a good sign heroes don't torture people
on the surface agatha's fate seems
pretty clear
at the end of episode 7 breaking the
fourth wall we learn the woman we
knew as agnes isn't a westview resident
attracted by wanda's magic
agatha uses her own powers to inject
herself
into one disillusions after agatha loses
her battle against wanda in the series
finale
the scarlet witch doles out what seems
like a fitting and poetic punishment
she transforms agatha into the same
nosey neighbor she's pretending to be
since the beginning of wandavision
but what has a scratching our heads is
that shortly after transforming agatha
wanda undoes her reality changing hex
the illusory west view of which agatha
pretended to be a citizen
no longer exists meaning that agatha is
now a sitcom character for a sitcom that
doesn't
exist so where did she go the only
answer we can come up with
is that agatha is now a resident of the
real west view
and that answer is kind of well insane
even if you forget the obvious ethical
question of doing to agatha what wanda
has done
what about the rest of westview's
citizens wanda has already put these
people through an absolute horror show
of trauma and violation
and now she's going to force upon them
an everyday reminder of what they've
been through in the form of a powerful
and power-hungry sorceress as their
neighbor
stay classy wanda in the fourth episode
of wandavision
we interrupt this program we find out
exactly how monica rambo got involved in
the westview case
returning to active duty and sword rambo
is assigned as
liaison to fbi agent jimmy woo who we
first meet in 2018's ant-man and the
wasp
close up magic
i learned that rambo meets wu outside
westview where he tells rambo that he's
there looking for someone in witness
protection
but we never get any indication whether
wu successfully locates the witness
one theory some fans are batting around
is that wu's witness is the same guy
who's been masquerading as wanda's
brother
in the finale we learned that the false
pietro is named ralph boner
and that agatha has been controlling him
with some kind of mystical
necklace boner
boner when monica says his name out loud
ralph laughs at the obvious joke most
people don't laugh at their own names
but
ralph does come off as someone who upon
entering witness protection
might have given himself a funny name on
purpose it's all
pretty unclear we end up not knowing
much of anything about the guy
if this is the case however it's strange
that ralph seems to be an aspiring actor
you wouldn't
think someone in witness protection
would want to get a job that would give
him more
public exposure then again ralph doesn't
seem like the sharpest tool in the shed
the minds of the people inside the west
view hex aren't the only ones affected
by wanda's magic
when monica first meets jimmy wu outside
the few town limits
will as the east view sheriff repeat
what he told wu before she arrived
that the town of westview new jersey
doesn't exist
no such place as she sends her drone
into the hex
monica wonders aloud about the nature of
this memory loss including asking why it
affects the east view sheriff and his
deputy but
not wu or her she asks whether someone
needs to have a personal connection to
someone in the town to be affected or
if it has more to do with a specific
radius around
the town but while we get monica's
questions
between this scene in episode 4 and the
series finale
we never get an answer toward the end of
the finale we're left to assume
billy and tommy disappeared along with
the dream vision when wanda took down
the hex
but in a post-credits scene we see wanda
pouring over the darkhold
just before hearing the voices of her
children calling out to her for help
does this mean they could return we know
that in the comics the souls of billy
and tommy are reincarnated in the forms
of very real boys who in turn become the
young avengers wiccan and speed
but before that their souls are claimed
by the devilish mephisto
and this is one of the many reasons one
division fan theorists
believed the villain might show up in
the series while that never happened
could it be that mephisto now has the
twins he's
gotta show up eventually right perhaps
it isn't mephisto who has
the twins but another powerful marvel
mystic entity
while it isn't confirmed one of the more
prominent rumors of doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness
in which wanda will appear is that the
villain will be nightmare who controls a
realm of dark dreams
considering the dream world wanda
creates in one division
wouldn't it make sense that she'd
attracted his attention
one division leaves us wondering exactly
who
or what this new version of wanda is
particularly in terms of whether or not
we can still
counter on the side of the angels during
their battle agatha tells wanda that the
darkhold says the scarlet witch is
destined to destroy the world it could
be
she was lying but once she reveals
herself to wanda
lying doesn't seem to be her style
everything else she says to wanda tends
to be true
she just reveals it with as much venom
as she can muster
we know in the comics wanda has gone
down some very dark paths
in the line-wide event avengers
disassembled she causes the crisis
leading to the deaths of three avengers
in house of m
she transforms the entire world and at
the end of the event
she tries to completely strip all
mutants of their powers
and succeeds in all but a small
percentage
so you know being a bad guy isn't
exactly alien territory for her
and her actions at the end of one
division are ambiguous as far as this
goes
she brings down the hex which is
definitely a good thing
but she doesn't apologize to any of
westview's people she doesn't turn
herself into the authorities
and she punishes agatha in a way that
while fitting
is genuinely cruel who knows
when she shows up in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness maybe
she won't be there to help the sorcerer
supreme
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one